人間って僕このもともと僕は放送局なんでそのやっえっとね
まあムっているわけじゃないけど1ぐらいから作り上げないといけないわけですよ
だそうすると這うだー how じゃダメなんですよね
あの
基本的にそれとか自分が行ったりイベントとか番組っていうのは人格が出るんですよ
だ自分がこそ糸さあこそい番組であるしなんか自分が何かこう計算計算してたらなんか
こう儲け主義のイベントになっていくし
だからこれはね違うなと思ってそれから
ホワイトハウの量面を研究するようになったわけですよね
ってその時に人間つが基本的にホワイトハウが2つないといけないわけですよねえ
why が100で90で9.99
how があるので一番いいわけですねこれ why があって羽生が50中の来れば
勝ちバカなんですね
でその逆に言えばあの how が
why を通り過ぎるといわゆる金儲け主義のあんまり尊敬されない人になっちゃう
わけですよ
でも一番いいのは
ああああああ
how が100で90的球電球の
why 金を開い金100で基準や救急のハウがあるこれが完璧なわけですよね
でそうしたことを考えたときに今この社会どうだろうと
ほとんど how で一蘭かということなんですよ
だからたとえばその相手を好きになるときにあの
年収がいくらとかねせがーどんくらいとかねそういうことをがんばったりするじゃない
ですか
でも
自己紹介するときに僕は身長が何政治で血糖値が何で体脂肪がなんという言い方しませ
んよね
僕の性格はこういう性格でこういう思いがあってこういうしてますということによって
相手は好きになるわけだからそれはイベントでも仕事でも何でも僕は一緒だと思うわけ
ですよ
で戦後やっぱり我々日本
エンジンはあのいかにして生きるかは学校で学んできたんでその活かしていけるかって
言って基金今見抜きでいかにしていきましたいいきてますってたらすぐ答えられると
思うんですよ
朝何時に起きて何キロカロリーとって何やってないって今日鮭ので寝ますみたいな
でもなぜしてノート本で聞いたときに
と言えないと思うんですよなぜ生きてる顔そういうそれそれは皆さんが悪いんじゃなく
て
教えられてないから誰からも
誰からも知られてないんですよでもこれは戦前とがいる子だいとう日本人とはきっちり
教えられてるわけですよね
なぜ生きるか要は目的ですよねだから今生きてるの手段の生き方しかしてない
なぜ生きるかという目的の良い稼働しないって言う
なんで
これからはこの why を我々は大切にしていってそれを世界に広めていきたいと
そのためにはまず福岡からそれをやりましょうということが僕の目的なんですよ
でそれをやる時に
いきなりホワイトいって言ってますがこんなことやったら多分半分はよ僕は僕はよ僕が
一応社会的に仕事してるから
アーマー岩隈さんの言うことだからキーところになるけど男全然知られてこんなこと
言ったら混ぜ宗教宗教の教祖と間違えられますからね
赤あねそういう
ただだから我々はこれをちょっとエンターテインメントを通じてイベントを通じてそっ
からみんなで広げていきたいわけですよ
でその結局
why を学ぶには版を極めないとまぁいけないということもあるわけですよね
あの例えば県土をやるときに礼に始まり礼に終わるって言うけど
わからんですよそんなこと言われてもどんなもねーよそんなもん強けりゃ市場やろう
なんて思って
で僕買ってめちゃくちゃ強くなって最後にどっかで優勝した時に
あら剣道っていうのは強いだけじゃないんだなぁと礼節が大事なんだなと思うわけです
よ
だから版から入って why 覚えるということがあるんで我々はそういうの
イベントを通じてやっていこうとそれもちょっと分かりやすいソフト産業
いわゆるエンターテインメントとかクリエイトいうとこにクリエイティブの世界になる
とかなり終わりのところに近いんでそこから
を愛の方に持っていくようなことを我々はしたいと思って
で
例えば今みんな頭が既成概念があるでそうまあ言われたらまあを開いちゃわかるねって
言ったときにじゃあ皆さんにしてもしたいんですけど
花はなぜきれいに咲くんですか
oris 申し訳ないよねあ聞けないね花はなぜきれいに作家
これ how 的な答えそれは3期連載からミツバチの日人が飛んで行ってそこで自公
教えとか[ __ ]とって教えてメスにくっつけていく自分作業ですね
いわゆる子孫繁栄そういうために花はきれいに咲くんだと言う
触れることを学校で習うと思うんですよ
そしたらそれは
8がきれいに見ればいい話ですよね8からとって花はきれいに見れば see 話で
あって
確かに犬は反応しませんよね色各細胞がないから犬は小便かけるぐらいなんです
何もしないんだから
逆にじゃあ人間は花を見てはどうですか綺麗に見えますよね
じゃあ人間が綺麗な花がそこにあったらどうします
先ほど大学教授のちゃいましたでしょつ切りますよ多分あっ一羽シートを
ちぎって持って行ってとかやるなったら同じようにあげますよ
あんたさぁやってもさっきの教授んそれからエキスを抽出するでしょうねうんなくなる
でしょうけど
あああのね羽成とっちゃいい迷惑ですよ
だから鼻から下室も反映であれば
人間カフェた時に来たねカッコショタがいいんですよ
だからよく海外旅行の競技で日本じゃあ金持ちと思われるから貧乏な格好してわざと
言ったりするじゃないですか
そうすると泥棒に合わないといっしょでそこにあったら腹からしたのさ
人間から見たら絶対俺ちょっとやばいって思うはずでしょ
じゃあなぜ肌が綺麗にされているかですよこれを why 的に見ないとき
ないですよみんな how 的に見てるけどホエイ的に見るとですね
私は考えました
これはねー
人間を喜ばせているために伝えている
そうやって歩きました
さっきの教授の人みたいに no yama を奏するタンポポがありました
たんぽぽどっち向いてます
上も入れますよね幸あれ浮いてると思うぜ人間向いてるんですよねっ
例えば桜花見しますよね花見したらはぁどっち向いてます
その辺後ろ人もいるでしょう群人なんでしょ
担保は上を向いてるので桜をした方がいいというわけですよ
オーラムてたこれやったと思いながらでも待ってよと
5月ぐらいだってまあツツジとかさつきはバーそう煽れも遊ゴロそうでもないんだろう
なぁと思ってポンというかな鍋浮いてるんですよ
うううううは本誓グリスをグーッとしてさ自分で
だから花はねええ
人のために咲いてるわけですよこういう why があると明日からね
もう花を見るともう慈しんでたまらんですよ
どんな花でも綺麗に見えますよ本当に運営
じゃあ例えばねあのお風呂
お風呂でお水水は
あっためるとどっちが厚くてどっちが住みたいですか
あっためるぞ
上から熱くなって下が緩いですよねじゃあ凍らせると
表面から凍っ天皇黒水でしょお子もおかしいと思いません
あった目たら上が厚くてしたか冷たくて冷やすと
上に集めたくてしたがあったかいんですよ
おかしいでしょこれはハウ的に説明てくるんですよ
摂氏4度で水の比重が変わるんですよだから逆転するんです
ここまでは学校で習いますなりますこれ以上は教えてくれない
学校の先生に聞いてもだから私は文系に来ましたこれだけじゃないけどなんでねあのう
それをですで how 的に考えアホ愛的に考えると猫良くなるんですよ
フォロワー数でしょこれはガチで酔っぱらって帰って来てうわーってパッと入ったら
熱いじゃないですか
をチェックするわけですよおっちゃっちゃっちゃってねでも初子冷たかったらさあ
酔っ払っです
それぞ入ったらさそのが焼けるするじゃないですか
ねっこれででパっ子凍らせますよね
凍らせてよ凍らせて上がこうランディング友好なんてしただけ凍ったらすぅみぃたん
相良全部凍りますわ
サーパラささから取れんでしょ
だからそういう風に髪探してるんですよちゃんと
why ナースだか
なぜしてるかで人間のために全て作られている
そのこうなりますもんだからそれをちゃんとこう穴あけてこう釣れるようにしとるわけ
ですよねそうやっても論語とは見ていたら面白いのか
例えばじゃあ顔はどうなっている人の顔
目が合って腹がって口があるこれ口上にあったらどうなります
ブーバー全部考えられてるけどなーぜねぇだからなぜいいいかに大事かあっああああっ
ブービーを聞きたければあここからユーロサーマル並ぶうならぬファー
ata 例えばですよ粘土とそこ6じゃないですか
ね ok ok
年度おいとってっ
おいておりますよね明日なったらどうなっています
年度でしょ100年経っても年度ですよ
ねでもそれをツボにするにはどうしたらいいですか
それは人間がこれでツボを作ろうという意志が働いてすごくを作るわけですねこっちゃ
すぐになるわけですよ
そしては今
世界考えてください今井華137億年前まで6ですよ
ねこんな難題世界がある137億年前は胸んですよ
うんそれから来 bigbang が何か起きたな
bigbang 産カキ棚でさんかめりこの世界ができてるわけですよね
ダラ
9産んでねだから何もなかったら何もないでいいはずなんですよ
のままでいいじゃん別いるものもあって名もいらんよ別にのでいいはずなのにこんな
不便な者がなぜ作ったかというと誰かが作った
誰かがその年度こうやったわけですよ
そう言ってあれかっちゅうことは蘭丸私は神と思うんですけど
まああいべもあると思うんだけどもまずは人それぞれ考えていただいて水意思が働いて
いるということは
まぁ事実ではあるということなんですよ
でまぁそんなもんだしながら
エースは良いものを這うも大事だということで我々は仕事をやるときに
ろバーンその晩我慢っていうのをやってくれますよ
男はロマンそろばん我慢夜は我慢しない嫌なんだけどあんでそういう感じで私たちは
仕事をやっております
で
今ね僕はやってるちょっと日で流してもらえれば行為国ちょっとわからんですよ話して
で今あのちょっとイベント簿買取福岡者コレクションと
えー何だっけ a アジェジャンパーティガージャンパー t と a
もう一個東京 tgc 東京ガールズコレクションの北九州中の3本参考ねちょ
チャットやったんでそれはあの
見せてもらえばいいですはいで面白い音ズレ準備
てたのにまだやっはーいを張ったっていうどうしようと思ってくださいね
ただもうちょっとね僕らがまぁそうやってまずエンターテインメントやるときにあの
心がけているのは
6からは作れないですはっきり6から作るのは髪だけです
私は一から作ります一から作るというのはどういうことかというとみなさん学習という
ことがわかります
学習する者を学習しました色んなものだ
ねこれこれこれですよねっでこういうのはあの学習したわけですよ学習の額っていうの
は
訓読みすると学ぶなんですよね
まなぶの
語源は
マネる学習の主主は
習うならうの語源はなれる
まれて慣れるまでてなる生まれてる人がパクるチョコなんですよ
あー全て海外とかねいいと言っていいとかパクってきてここを持ってくればいいだけな
んですよ
そんなねゼロから作るとかで高尚なことをねいうのは神様だけで言って我は私は人間な
んであの
そういうのを持ってきてアレンジしていくわけですよ
すべてはそうですよじゃないと我々のこの日本日本を感じにしても中国が持ってきたり
してるわけだから
すべてまず1なんかこうつながってできてきているからこういうのもそうやってできて
くるわけですよね
で
その我々やってるのはこれは福岡アジアコレクションであって別に吹く福岡&に行って
診て複合かー
a ジャジャンコレクション9駅車みたいでもやってませんが僕ら
僕らやったら福岡アジアコレクションなんですよ
ああパリでやってるのはこれくしょん私が買ってるのは
コレクションこれ違うんですよあのアメリカにあるのははい
アメリカでコンビニは何ですかこれゴミに弱視とはじゃあそれをだから
セブンイレブンでしょ surf セブンイレブンその7選ばん
セブンイレブンねで国日本にあるのは
セブンイレブンなんですよある別もんなんよ全然
だからアメリカ等も7セブンイレブンに行ったらもうもうアバウトですよめちゃくちゃ
めちゃくちゃパワーですよでも日本7厘セブンイレブンに行ったらパパンと
めちゃくちゃおじゃりやれば最近ではなかっなくどんな側で言ってるんですかねえで
セブンイレブンだ後存在とかめちゃくちゃうまいですからね
すごいよそれが日本のアレンジなんですよ
似て非なるものの全く違うだからあの
ナポリタン
アントニオと思い至りましただけ置いてないあれはいわゆる洋食という和食なんですよ
オムライスにしても養殖という和食を作り出されてポンジ
ねっで採れた準社が作ってブルースがあれはオートモービルではないんですよ
あるいは自動車っていう別問題フェラーリはオートモービルなんですよね
我々は自動車理由を作って
は行ってはルフランコレアイドル出してもいいと思ってるもんだから
アイドルはてるはファッションショーにだろこれクリエーターズ別なやつで edm と
か
あの edm の民主化ってやってんです edm というのが今世界中で流行ってて
その言われクラブ文化ですよね
でもクラブ文化はとんがっててこれはなかなかとしてたら生きにくいじゃないですか
生き抜けるけどたぶんこの世代では dx ディスコ世代だからクラブのがある楽よね
これでジャンプするだけ検査
検察は楽なんですよ同じルってもうちょっとダンス結構覚え何かあったからいまが楽な
んだけどそういうクラブ文化を持っとこう
民主化させようと老若男女よう edm みたいな世界をつくりたいならこの xp
トリックプレーでこういう
福岡市福岡市にマッピングしたんですよ
福岡市役所もこれにあの議会からめちゃくちゃ文句言われましたけど
行ったんですよでこれはあのねこれねすごい世界的なアーティストで
なんだっけこず見比べて言ってあの映像とこれは伝統音楽とクラブと映像のあの
コラボレーションみたいな
八尾こうやってやったりしてこれあの子の中で音は公開
公開ゲーム公開対戦ゲームこれあの服をこれ ipad であるんですよこういうの
やっていますよ
ねこれがあのわれあーこれトリポリ鶏ムネ
ドリームて7位があるにがある
でへ
まぁコレとかコレアイドルアイドル福岡だって今のメジャーデビューしてるのか4組で
後字が18クラってすごいんですよ福岡らアイドル市場はもろすぐ今盛り上がってて
これで中10万人ぐら集まりましたので3日間ですねこれこれは dream 5の
あの妖怪ウォッチこれもレベル4
福岡だからで僕らはこういうちょっとクリエイティブをてまでして
今福岡市とかへ
会社もそうだけどへ
まちづくりをやっていますそして僕が行きたいのはこっから why に行きたいわけ
ですよ次のせいかそれは多分さっき言ったように顕著と一緒でものから入ってあとは
一人一人なんで皆さんも一人一人が羽生の生き方から
why の生き方になっていただくそれをまず福岡から初めて
それを国家ラベルして why 国家日本をつ日本をつくってそして世界をこの why
でまとめていきたい
それができるのはばあちゃん日本だけだと思うんですよこんなあんたこの
浸透国家同棲前へ here あのう
なんていうかあの
あれこれでえっと
そういう
ヒロミさんなんて言ってるんだっけんであの
なんてぃあそう思いやりね大槍が多いといっただけどそう日本じゃそういう数字持っ
てるんですよ
持ってるからでそれは神道って成立性善説の国だからところが世界はすべて製薬雪の国
にやられたわけですよ性善説の九里はすべて
唯一まゆいつぐらい章あとなんかあるかもしれないけど唯一残ってるの日本国だけだ
これ不思議と言われる理由この
この業界ではでそのそうするこの国が性善説で唯一残ったということはこの国が世界を
良くした方が絶対に良くなる
絶対に良くなるだから我々が
今生きている我々が貴重なんですよ
我々がやんないといけないんですよ我々が福岡から
そして日本そして世界へ行っていく
僕がそれを皆様に伝えるために
こういうイベントもやりながら今を生きておりますてぺじゃあこれこれ世界
わけですねこれねねぇこれから金が目にみたいにいろんな
クリエイティブをここに持ってきてごっちゃにして新しい文化を作っていきたいと思っ
ています
最後にん
すべてのハウは why のためにご静聴ありがとうございました